hey everybody it's Mike frieder with
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control ac.l
2-3.1.12. monitoring control remote
access sessions
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
is feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
trying to understand all this cmmc
defars and nist SP 800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in cmmc control
ac.l2-3.1.12 monitoring control remote
access sessions we are first declaring
if remote access sessions are allowed
then figuring out what's allowed then
learning about how they are controlled
and finally figuring out if they are
monitored this is a control which is a
little different than past controls in
that it has a progressive assessment
Cadence where each assessment Point goes
a little bit more in depth than the last
one let's take a look at the assessment
points and here's some sample answers so
four assessment points on this one first
one is determine if remote access
sessions are permitted so obviously you
know it's more of an answer simple
answer it's gonna be yes but you're
probably going to have to show an
assessor this is actually happening now
second one is determine if the types of
permitted remote access are identified
so obviously there's a lot of different
types of remote access to make a really
simple excuse me example what we'll do
is we'll just say yes and then we'll say
let's say the organization's got a VPN
right so we'll Define hey it's a VPN
maybe we'll show them the firewall we'll
actually let them see hey yep there's a
VPN right here here's the settings
third piece determine if remote access
sessions are controlled yes we're doing
it by VPN and let's say that I don't
know we've got it LinkedIn through
active directory and the active
directory accounts and permissions uh
along with maybe MFA are what is
controlling whether or not someone gets
access boom it's control show a
demonstration of that
now fourth assessment Point determine if
remote access sessions are monitored
now we have a little different answer so
obviously we're going to say yes VPN
etcetera remote access sessions are
monitored by the same solution right our
security information event management
firewall monitoring as well is important
and hopefully they're tied together and
periodically during risk assessments
right so during risk assessments we want
to assess and make sure these sessions
are still being monitored that's how I'd
answer it if it was me and of course uh
if you're looking for more help on this
stuff we are your source so an on-call
we work with defense contractors just
like you who've had this dfar's nist
itar and cmmc compliance stuff dropped
in their lap like a seal on a sunny day
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you and if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc complianceecrets.com
that's cmmc compliance secrets dot com
where we give away all the secrets to
getting compliant fast and easy or check
out the bio below for links to help get
help right now if you love the content
we're putting out there for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button you know we love seeing that
really tells us we're doing the right
thing here and even better smash that
subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
complianceers roll it out until next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]